focus on one target market starting the
business is tough getting new customers
that come in the door is tough and the
best way to do it is to pick a niche be
great at what you do really solve the
problem for that target market and if
you need to from there expand to new
markets new products new services but
start with one key market in mind that
gets you to and past the point of
survival where you don't to go back and
get another job because if you're trying
to be everything to everybody you're
just gonna be average playing boring and
people gonna ignore you
you want to be amazing great excellent
the best to some people and other people
can hate you or ignore you if you look
at my business I help entrepreneurs I
love helping entrepreneurs I'm really
good at it it fuels me it drives me gets
me excited I deal with entrepreneurs I'm
on the phone on the radio on YouTube I
get motivated I love talking to you guys
if you're not an entrepreneur you're
probably not following my channel you
probably don't know who I am you
probably don't care about me and I'm
fine with that because I love
entrepreneurs that's my niche you got to
find your niche you got to find the one
segment of the market that you help you
are amazing at being able to help and
focus on having them love you and then
if you need to later expand but that's
how you start your business I got a
question from one of my YouTube viewers
I love you guys
men's sewer so Mansell wrote in I'm
starting in the business you think it's
better to focus on one part of society
like teenagers for example and get the
most out of your product for them or
focus on everyone even though you won't
get any agreement from one side or the
other
absolutely focus on the one market so if
it's teenagers go for teenagers
teenagers still is a huge market so Penn
what your product or service is I would
still refine that a little bit more but
I definitely go off the teenagers
instead of everybody you want teenagers
to love you to adore you to to be lining
up outside your store to be clicking on
your website every day even if the
adults and the kids hate you or ignore
you because those guys are going to lead
you to profitability they're gonna lead
you to having an impact great businesses
are started from a niche market that
then expand even the huge businesses if
you look at Facebook
Facebook is mainstream right Facebook is
a huge company right now but when they
started it was only for university
campuses so whose only university
students college students who were
signing in to Facebook it was meant for
that community and they loved it and
they made it to survival and beyond they
were making money from that but then it
was so helpful and so useful and so
addictive that people those those hike
those university kids they brought in
their parents and they brought in older
people and younger people into the
market and it grew into this massive
company but it started with a loyal
loving amazing fan base so you you would
much rather have somebody love you and
fight with their friends over you saying
what are you talking about this guy is
amazing you need to strike that kind of
emotion up with people you need to get
word-of-mouth happening for your company
and that's something gonna happen when
you stand for something that caters to a
specific demographic because nobody's
gonna love you for everything and if
you're boring you're gonna get lost if
your mediocre you're gonna get lost in
the shuffle and you're not going to be
successful so pick one market something
you know something you feel passionate
about something that excites you really
dive deep and help them be the best at
what you do change their lives for the
better and they will help spread the
word to other people like them and maybe
later take you to new markets but that's
the way to start be successful get to
the point of survival and get beyond and
build a company that you can be proud of
and say I did that I change those
people's lives believe so those are you
watching like the video thumbs up below
thank you so much I love those coming in
and let me know what you think leave a
comment I watch them every morning I log
into my computer I eat my breakfast and
I'm looking at the comments and it makes
my day to see them come in so even if
just seeing you liked the video leave
that below if you have a question for me
leave a below make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you